[Music]  you know the Beatles yes I know who they  are cause you took Eleanor Rigby who  Eleanor Rigby I don't know no Yellow  Submarine you know so many that's silly  it's very funny you've been one of my  harshest critics the way he lives  criticism your shoes a criticism  you don't like my shoes you think you  know better and they are no longer part  of this world you know the hardest thing  is to listen to hear his voice  God's fires  it's not me or needs to be satisfied its  1.2 million believe your science the  others are saying God always corrects  one Popeye presenting the world with  another corporation I'd like to see my  correction  [Music]  you